[Aplausos]
[Música]
dos nuevos países han surgido en el
tablero político mundial O al menos en
el mapamundi ruso en el pasado lunes 21
de febrero el presidente de la
federación rusa Vladimir Putin firmó los
decretos que reconocen la independencia
de la República Popular de dones y la
República Popular de lugansk en el este
de Ucrania y eso no es todo el
presidente ruso también le ordenó a su
ministro de defensa el despliegue
inmediato del ejército ruso en estas dos
nuevas repúblicas para llevar a cabo una
operación de mantenimiento de la paz lo
que por supuesto en palabras de Putin
significa demostrar que controlas el
territorio
de hecho en esta misma línea el propio
gobierno ruso ha enviado a la duma para
su ratificación los tratados de defensa
y seguridad alcanzados con las nuevas
repúblicas populares dos tratados que
por supuesto y como no podía ser de otra
manera le encarga la muscula protección
de estos territorios le facultan para
desplegar tropas y le permiten construir
bases militares en ellos vamos que
estamos ante una de esas grandes obras
de teatro que tanto gustan en Moscú aquí
en visualpolitik ya os contamos como
esta jugada el reconocimiento pleno de
la independencia de estas dos repúblicas
era algo más que probable Por así
decirlo es una jugada que forma parte
del manual habitual de Moscú es algo que
ya hemos visto en los casos de
transnistria fascia y osetia del Sur con
todo el despliegue de tropas rusas en
las autoproclamadas repúblicas populares
de dones y luans supone la primera
incursión formal de tropas rusas en
territorio legalmente ucraniano y una
violación flagrante de los acuerdos de
mix 2 algo que ha disparado la tensión y
el miedo a que esta operación sea solo
el preludio de una invasión a gran
escala
[Música]
lo que por cierto sigue siendo negado
por el propio presidente de Ucrania Bajo
su punto de vista de este movimiento a
pesar de suponer Sí una Clara violación
de la soberanía del país y de los
acuerdos de Miss 2 simplemente a
legalizado la actividad que el ejército
ruso lleva realizando la región desde el
año 2014 Por así decirlo la realidad que
todo el mundo conocía que
moscúnegaba Y que ahora nos alarma que
se haya confirmado sobre todo si tenemos
en cuenta como Rusia ha rodeado Ucrania
por tierra mar y aire
sea como sea el caso amigos es que toda
esta situación pone sobre la mesa unas
cuantas preguntas Qué consecuencias
puede tener este reconocimiento qué
supone para el conflicto entre Rusia
Ucrania y occidente y la pregunta que la
hora de la verdad puede que a muchos más
os explique la curiosidad cómo son
exactamente esta repúblicas Pues bien
veamoslo
[Música]
las nuevas repúblicas populares
desde su autoproclamada independencia en
el año 2014 las nuevas repúblicas han
quedado aisladas casi por completo del
resto de Ucrania Bueno del resto de
Ucrania y prácticamente de todo el mundo
con la excepción Claro está de Rusia hoy
forman uno de los territorios más opacos
cerrados y militarizados de todo el
planeta la República Popular de donex
tiene unos 8.900 kilómetros cuadrados y
unos 2,3 millones de habitantes y este
hombre que veis en pantalla Denis
pusiling Que formó parte de una enorme
estafa piramidal en Rusia y Ucrania es
su líder por su parte la República
Popular de logans tiene unos 8.300
kilómetros cuadrados y 1,6 millones de
habitantes en total hablamos de unos
17.300 kilómetros cuadrados el
equivalente a la superficie de Kuwait o
socielandia y 3,9 millones de habitantes
Aunque la población podría ser en
realidad muy inferior digamos que
resulta difícil de precisar por los
enormes desplazamientos de población que
ha provocado el conflicto que comenzó en
el año 2014 el año que dio forma estas
dos nuevas repúblicas
[Música]
amigos el día 22 de febrero del 2014 el
por aquel entonces presidente de Ucrania
y Aliado de Moscú Víctor yanukovic huyó
de la capital y dejó su puesto como
consecuencia de las protestas desatadas
por la revolución de la humanidad y ahí
justo ahí es cuando comenzó la tormenta
[Música]
Rusia respondió a la revolución del
euromaidane anexionándose crimea con los
famosos hombres de verde y alimentando
la sublevación del este del país sin
embargo si la toma de crimea fue limpia
los levantamientos en el este de Ucrania
fueron un caos las protestas en
Indonesia y lugans pronto dieron paso a
un conflicto armado entre el nuevo
gobierno de Ucrania y las milicias
locales respaldadas por Moscú
inicialmente Los Rebeldes prorrusos
avanzaron rápido y se hicieron con el
control de la práctica totalidad de los
oblast de donés y lugans sin embargo el
contraataque del ejército ucraniano y
particularmente de los batallones de
voluntarios obligaron a Rusia a enviar
tanques baterías antiaéreas y artillería
de largo alcance para frenar la ofensiva
y obligar a Ucrania a pactar un alto el
fuego y firmar los acuerdos de Minsk 2
desde entonces la línea del frente se ha
mantenido más o menos estable
Los acuerdos de mix 2 fueron un intento
de poner fin al conflicto impulsados por
Francia y Alemania con el escepticismo
de Estados Unidos y el acuerdo reconocía
la soberanía ucraniana a cambio de que
kiev le otorgara a las regiones
sublevadas un estatus de autonomía
especial Claro que las definiciones
fueron imprecisas y al final ninguna de
las partes cumplió su palabra en
cualquier caso si por ahí algo está
claro es que por mucho que moleste en
Bruselas una vez que Rusia ha reconocido
la plena independencia de estos
territorios estos acuerdos ya no valen
nada son papel mojado
además el conflicto nunca se terminó el
fuego de los francotiradores y los
intercambios de artillería Fueron
constantes por ambos bandos en total se
calcula que esta guerra ha causado entre
14.000 y 20.000 víctimas mortales además
de por lo menos dos millones de
desplazados En otras palabras que los
acuerdos de mings 2 fueron Otra de esas
grandilocuentes operaciones europeas
repletas de buenas intenciones pero que
a la hora de la verdad nadie se las cree
Ni siquiera los propios firmantes y El
caso es que así es como surgieron las
nuevas repúblicas populares de donex y
luganos dos repúblicas que viven
prácticamente bajo un estado de guerra
permanente las instituciones amigos
fueron asaltadas se impuso un modelo
ultranacionalista conservador y
militarizado y muchas por no decir la
mayoría de las grandes empresas y de los
activos productivos como las minas o las
fábricas de acero fueron expropiadas
opuestas a disposición de oligarcas
amigos de Moscú Este es por ejemplo el
caso de
un inversor Ruso que ahora controla los
activos más valiosos y sí también se ha
establecido un modelo político policial
de manufactura han logrado reconstruir
un sistema soviético en los territorios
ocupados y no el sistema sovi de las
décadas de 1960 y 1970 sino el sistema
soviético de las décadas de 1930 y 1940
como mazmorras con cámaras de tortura un
sistema donde las vidas se arruinan si
te atreves a escribir o decir algo
negativo sobre esta repúblicas y sus
autoridades están aisladas en novelista
y periodista de donesk y ojo porque
hablamos del que era uno de los
territorios más desarrollados de todo
Ucrania por supuesto tal y como os
podéis imaginar todo esto ha tenido
consecuencias atentos
[Música]
la ruina
hoy Parece difícil de creer pero hace
apenas una década donex fue una de las
sedes más importantes de la Eurocopa del
año 2012 una Eurocopa que fue organizada
por Ucrania y Polonia para albergar esta
competición en la ciudad se vistió de
gala se restauró buena parte de la
ciudad se construyó un nuevo aeropuerto
se arreglaron las carreteras y Se
abrieron nuevos y relucientes hoteles
tampoco resultaba extraño las regiones
de donex y formaban el conocido como
cinturón del óxido el motor económico de
todo Ucrania un importante en clave
minero industrial El Hogar De Las
mayores acerías de todo el país y no
solo eso donex también en el hogar y la
principal sede del Emporio de rinad a
que metoff el hombre más rico de todo
Ucrania un multimillonario cuya fortuna
Forbes Calcula en unos 7.000 millones de
dólares pero o sea como sea el caso es
que hoy todo eso ha quedado atrás
las infraestructuras están dañadas el
servicio de telefonía móvil e internet
es irregular en el mejor de los casos la
actividad económica se ha desplomado los
empleos han desaparecido y cerca de la
mitad ojo la mitad de la población
podría haber emigrado al resto de
Ucrania Rusia y al resto de Europa sobre
todo a Polonia Y por supuesto las
empresas y las cadenas internacionales
han cerrado sus puertas a calicanto
solía ver mucho entusiasmo por la
República Popular de donesk al principio
todos coreaban dpr dpr dpr Ahora solo
hay mucha decepción la economía Allí se
ha desmoronado los puestos de trabajo Se
han ido no hay nada bueno allí Alexander
gallebol exiliado de la región de donesk
hoy estas dos repúblicas se han
convertido en territorios muy pero que
muy pobres dos territorios que viven
esencialmente del contrabando y de la
financiación rusa Y es que de hecho en
ellas todo es Rusia la moneda de curso
oficial es el rublo a sus ciudadanos se
les expide pasaportes rusos tienen
acceso a los beneficios sociales de
Rusia y sus mandatarios se han Unido al
propio político de Putin vamos que lo de
la independencia es un poco de broma
hablamos mejor y si eso de autonomía y
como mucho
el futuro además no parece nada
halagüeño sin reconocimiento
internacional las inversiones y el
comercio no tienen muy complicado para
colmo tras el reconocimiento de su
independencia por parte de Rusia el
presidente Joe biden ha firmado una
orden ejecutiva que prohíbe que
cualquier empresa entidad o ciudadano de
los Estados Unidos participe directa o
indirectamente en proyectos de inversión
exportaciones importaciones financiación
o cualquier otro negocio con estos
territorios doneski lugans han quedado
aislados de la comunidad internacional
lo que hasta hace poco fue el lugar más
próspero de Ucrania hoy es una enorme
ruina
curiosamente han sido las ciudades
ucranianas del lombas las que han salido
más favorecidas hablamos de ciudades que
los últimos años han recibido montones
de trabajadores y empresarios de las
zonas controladas por Rusia
[Música]
y este es por ejemplo el caso de la
segunda ciudad más poblada de Ucrania
una ciudad que históricamente ha estado
muy ligada a Rusia y que fue uno de los
principales centros de producción
militar de la unión soviética una ciudad
que los Rebeldes prorrusos llegaron a
ocupar brevemente en el 2014 hasta que
fueron expulsados por una fuerza de
acción rápida del ejército ucraniano
Hablamos de una ciudad donde se calcula
que en 2014 apenas un tercio de la
población era Leal al gobierno ucraniano
un porcentaje amigos que ahora se podría
haber incrementado por encima del 70%.
Gracias precisamente a lo diferente que
ha sido su evolución económica respecto
a la que han tenido los territorios en
manos de Los rebeldes por rusos Sí el
mayor enemigo para Moscú puede ser
precisamente la falta de futuro que
entraña su ocupación viendo cómo están
las cosas en la propia Rusia como no van
a mirar los ucranianos hacia el oeste es
que es de cajón ahora bien hasta aquí
qué supone exactamente el reconocimiento
de Rusia porque ha generado tanta alarma
bien en primer lugar porque la operación
para el mantenimiento de la paz supone
la primera incursión reconocida de
tropas rusas en territorio ucraniano
pero también porque tarde o temprano
podría actuar como una excusa perfecta
para la invasión o cuánto menos para
mantener la atención Al rojo vivo fijaos
por ejemplo en este mapa
[Música]
en él podéis ver en color más oscuro el
territorio controlado por las repúblicas
populares y en color más claro el
territorio que reclaman la cuestión es
el reconocimiento ruso afecta también a
este territorio en disputa de ser Así
podríamos estar ante la justificación de
una invasión o acciones de agresión por
parte de las milicias de la repúblicas
populares que terminarán con el apoyo de
Moscú Rusia respalda la reclamaciones
territoriales completas de los
separatistas de Ucrania
Putin ha dicho públicamente que Rusia
respalda todas las reivindicaciones
territoriales de los separatistas
prorrusos eso sí también dijo que
correspondía a los separati puedas
negociar con kef la forma de resolver
esta disputa fronteriza eso puede
significar dos cosas por un lado la
excusa perfecta para lanzar una invasión
parcial sobre todo el don vas y quizás
también las costas del mar Negro si el
ejército ucraniano muestra resistencia
por otro puede ser la fórmula escogida
para Elevar aún más la tensión e
intentar lograr un tanto político en la
mesa de negociación y guardarse la baza
de la invasión para el futuro
[Música]
si esto es así la presencia de tropas
rusas no tendría porque suponer ningún
cambio Putin podría apuntarse al tanto
que tanto está buscando en casa y podría
evitar la mayoría de las sanciones
internacionales Joe biden impone una ola
de sanciones a Rusia por la invasión de
Ucrania el presidente de los Estados
Unidos se dirige a las élites algunos
bancos y la deuda soberana y dice que
seguirán más medidas y Putin avanza
Australia Canadá y Japón imponen
sanciones a Rusia por la crisis de
Ucrania en este caso el resultado para
Rusia seguiría siendo malo tal y como ya
os contamos en un pasado vídeo pero los
daños podrían ser un poquito más
limitados
[Música]
Claro que si finalmente el kremlin
decidir más allá bueno las experiencias
de donex y luans no nos permiten ser
optimistas con el futuro de los
ucranianos y tampoco ojo con el de los
propios rusos con una invasión no
ganarían nada y perderían mucho además
por supuesto de una rotunda condena
internacional tenemos información
creíble que indica que las fuerzas rusas
están creando listas de ucranianos
identificados para ser asesinados o
enviados a campamentos después de una
ocupación militar Es probable que las
fuerzas rusas utilicen medidas letales
para dispersar protestas pacíficas o
contrarrestar de otra manera los
ejercicios pacíficos de resistencia
percibida de las poblaciones civiles
badsiva crocker embajador de Estados
Unidos ante la oficina de las Naciones
Unidas pero llegados hasta aquí turno
para ti cómo piensas que van a discurrir
los acontecimientos será la intervención
en estas dos autoproclamadas repúblicas
populares El preludio de acciones
mayores déjanos tu respuesta por aquí
abajo en los comentarios y si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle muy pronto os hablaremos con todo
detalle del caso de Georgia Así que no
olvidéis suscribiros si aún no lo habéis
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]